on revendique le libre choix de chaque
agent chaque citoyen à pouvoir se faire
vacciner avec le vaccin qui le
souhaitent et au moment où le stade les
mesures seront applicables dès le
lendemain de la publication de la loi
donc si la date est maintenue au 9 août
donc ça veut dire que le 10 août déjà
tous les sapeurs pompiers qui pourront
intervenir sur le terrain devront être
soit vaccinée soit être porteur d'un
tests virologiques
ça va être très compliqué à organiser
pour les services à 108 secours
l'employeur qui est quand même le sdiss
va avoir de grandes difficultés à
organiser des cours et la distribution
des secours
[Musique]
à chaque fois qu'on a eu à demander à
revendiquer des choses comme ça a été
fait avec les forces de l'ordre avec le
corps médical
on nous a dit que nous étions
sapeurs-pompiers que nous n'étions pas
des personnels soignants donc n'ont pas
bénéficié des telles et telles mesures
qui pourraient et aujourd'hui lorsqu'il
est question de vous imposer
l'obligation de finale le ministre véran
annonce au lendemain de la déclaration
du président bacon que les sapeurs
pompiers seront vaccinés au prétexte
qu'ils sont des transporteurs sanitaires
[Musique]